-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Eddie Murphy.
So when did it occur to you,
"Hey, we have to go back.
We have to do a sequel
to this movie.
Enough time has passed"?
-Maybe about six years ago.
We had no idea we were going to
make this movie
when we finished
the original one.
It was like, the story ended,
and, like, they lived
happily ever after.
And then the movie,
over the years, became like --
it's the only one of my movies
that became like a cult movie,
where it has like an audience of
people that watch it
all the time and, you know,
some people get dressed up
on Halloween and [bleep].
There's a place that turns --
a restaurant that turns itself
into a McDowell's restaurant
on Halloween
and they have, like, Sexual
Chocolate malts on their menu.
-[ Laughs ]
-So it's like, that's --
I was like, "Hey, this movie is
a -- there's a cult following.
You know, if we could figure out
a way to connect those dots,
we could -- there's an audience
for this picture."
That was about six years ago.
-Don't get me wrong.
You and Arsenio have aged great.
But it's really fun to see
the barbershop characters
'cause none of them
have aged a day.
-No, they are older.
-You made them older.
-If you watch --
Watch the original movie.
You'll see they look much older.
-[ Laughs ] That's good.
-In the original movie,
they look like
they're in their,
like, early 60s,
and now they look like
they're in their early 90s.
[ Laughter ]
-One of the things that
must be so time-consuming is
sitting and getting into
the makeup like that.
But the freedom of playing
those extra characters,
it must be worth the time
you sit in the makeup chair.
-It's the most rewarding thing
when you do those and it works
and it's funny.
And the best thing, my favorite
thing is, lots of times,
people watch those movies
and they don't realize it's,
you know,
us doing those characters
'cause that's in the marketing
when the movie first comes out.
But once it's around,
people don't know.
They don't read the credits.
They just see it and, you know,
don't even realize it.
That's my favorite, when they
don't know that it's me,
and, you know, I tell them,
"Oh, I'm that old Jewish guy."
And they go,
"What are you talking about?"
"I'm the old Jewish guy,"
and they go "Ah!"
That's my favorite thing.
-Hey, I mean this sincerely.
This a free idea I want to --
because as you talk about
playing multiple characters,
I think the Oscars should start
doing something
where they give out an award
every year for a movie
that is 25 years old
that the Oscars admits
now deserved an Oscar.
And I feel like next year,
"The Nutty Professor"
should get the first of these
because I just feel like
it represents everything
that movies are supposed to be.
And when I think about
those dinner-table scenes,
and being lucky enough,
especially now,
when people aren't seeing
movies in theaters
with a bunch of people, like,
I remember being in a theater,
like, collectively
laughing like that.
And so that's my free pitch
to the Oscars,
is that you get the Oscar
you deserve for that movie.
-Aw, thank you so much, man.
That's one of my favorites, too.
-The amazing thing is just
the rhythm and pacing of scenes
where you realize,
"Oh, it's just you
in five different chairs."
And the fact that you have to
figure that out.
I mean, obviously a great deal
of it happens in editing.
But when you actually see the
finished product, are you also,
even though you were there
at different times,
are you blown away as well?
-Absolutely, yeah.
And like I said, it's rewarding,
but it's thankless
because if it's done
really, really well,
you can't see all the work
that went into it.
So, like, a scene around
the table that took, you know,
two weeks to shoot and that
whole sequence winds up being,
you know, three,
four minutes long,
and the audience isn't thinking
about any of that stuff.
So it's rewarding but thankless.
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- I mean,
it was worth it.
I want to tell you
I read that originally
Tracy Morgan was going to play
your son in this film
until you guys realized that,
I guess you only have about
a seven- or eight-year
age difference.
And it would maybe be
a hard sell.
-The third draft of the script,
we were still writing Tracy
as my son.
Then we started going,
"How -- Does Tracy --
Would you believe Tracy
was me and Leslie's son?"
And it was like,
"No, I don't believe that."
[ Laughter ]
We had to, you know,
turn him into the uncle.
-I like that in a movie
where there is so much
that's unbelievable,
that's the one journey
people aren't willing to make.
[ Laughter ]
They'll believe there's
a fictional African nation,
but they're like,
"I won't go for that."
[ Laughter ]
Wesley Snipes is also
really funny in this movie.
-Wesley is amazing
in this movie.
I did a movie last year with
him, "Dolemite Is My Name,"
and he was a hysterical
and just wonderful actor.
We had really great
screen chemistry,
so I went right into this movie
with him, and so happy.
I originally was going to play
General Izzi,
and I was like, "Wesley Snipes
would be so much better."
And he really, really --
He is funny and menacing
and just a great actor.
-There are -- You know, I don't
want to give away too much.
But I mean, it is really
fantastic the number of cameos,
the number of iconic people
not just from the '90s
but from the last 50 years.
At this point, is it pretty easy
for you to pick up the phone
and say to someone
like Morgan Freeman,
"I have a very good part for you
in this movie.
Would you do me a solid?"
Does that happen pretty simply
or is it hard?
-We were like, "Do you think
Morgan would do it?"
And we went through the agents
and all that stuff.
And when he did it,
we jumped around and danced.
It wasn't easy.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm glad to know it's still --
there are still people out there
that are hard for Eddie Murphy
to get.
-Yeah, we didn't think of it
as being easy.
And we thought we were
the luckiest people ever
when he said yes.
-Well, I can only imagine
what it was like being on set,
considering how enjoyable
it was to watch it.
I've got one thing --
I'll cut it out
if you don't want to answer it.
You know my friend Neal Brennan?
He's friends with you.
-Yes.
-He told me a story about how
Paul Mooney tried to beat you up
outside of The Comedy Store.
-No, not try beat me up.
[ Laughter ]
First of all, Paul Mooney
could never beat me,
not even when he was young.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, most comics, as far as
comics go, I'm pretty scrappy.
I don't know if I've met a comic
that, you know, could --
at any rate, but no, there was
an argument because I went --
they gave me the light the first
time I was at The Comedy Store.
Paul Mooney and them,
they gave me the light
because I was going on.
I just kept going and going.
I hadn't met Paul Mooney yet,
and they gave me the light.
And that was, like, first year
"SNL," and I was killing.
And I was like,
"They givin' me the light?"
And I was only there
for like 10 minutes,
and I said, "Who's supposed to
be coming on?"
They said, "Paul Mooney."
I said, "Who's Paul Mooney?"
And they said, "Yeah."
I said, "Do you want to see
me or Paul Mooney?"
And it was, "Aaaah!"
So I did like another hour
or some [bleep].
So when I came off the stage,
they were, like, crazy.
And Spoon, Witherspoon,
was in by the bathroom
at The Comedy Store,
and he said,
"Next time they tell you
to get off that stage,
you better get your [bleep]
off that stage."
I said, "Man, [bleep] you."
He said, "[Bleep] you
and [bleep] your mama, too!"
And we went outside
in the parking lot.
Then Mooney came walking up,
and he's like,
"Excuse me, homey.
Yes, you have a routine about
'The Amityville Horror'
about a ghost in the house?"
and I was like, "Yes."
He said, "Well, I have a routine
that's very similar.
Let me hear your routine,
homey."
And I was like, "I'm not doing
my [bleep] routine
in the parking lot."
And he said, "[Bleep] you."
And I was with John Landis.
He said, "[Bleep] you."
And he said, "And [bleep] you
too, white man.
If I had a knife -- if I had a
gun, I'd shoot the both of you."
[ Laughter ]
That was the first night
I met Paul Mooney.
And then Richard -- then when
Richard heard about it,
he took Mooney and Spoon,
and we took --
he made them come to the
main room at The Comedy Store
the next night, and -- after
hours -- and apologize to me.
-Wow.
-Richard made them apologize.
He was like, "You guys are
just being mean to that kid
because he's a new, hot [bleep]
and y'all was jealous.
And [bleep] that.
Y'all apologize."
Richard made them apologize.
Richard was always so nice.
And then Mooney became a great
friend, and Spoon as well.
But the very first night
I met them, Spoon was like,
"[Bleep] you and your mama!"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, needless to say,
I am glad I asked.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thanks so much, Eddie.
Please come back soon.
-Okay, Seth.
When it's all safe to come back,
I'll come check you out, bro.
-We'd really like that.
Thank you so much.
"Coming 2 America" is currently
streaming on Amazon Prime Video.